on the world trade center avaient été
construites avant l'adoption des normes
en vigueur aujourd'hui patrick fandio
nathalie gallet y aurait-il quelque
chose dit respirable dans l'air de
manhattan depuis qu'ils peuvent à
nouveau accéder au quartier du world
trade center
beaucoup de new yorkais n'y vont jamais
sans leur masque si certains en font un
usage inattendue pour la plupart ce
n'est pas juste une coquetterie
ils ne peuvent plus s'en passer
c'est un masque spécial pourquoi parce
qu'il a des filtres spéciaux pour la
poussière pour l'amiante il des trucs
comme ça
vous enlevez oui bien sûr le danger est
invisible mais omniprésent dans cette
fumée qui s'échappe des décombres du
world trade center des particules
d'amiante les tours jumelles construite
dans les années soixante dix contenait
ce matériau cancérigène
aujourd'hui c'est le fond de l'air qui
donne des frayeurs
je peux être ridicule comme ça mais mon
père est mort d'un cancer du poumon
je veux pas qu'il m'arrive la même chose
à quelques mètres de là dans cet hôpital
les consultations pour problèmes
respiratoires ont augmenté mais les
médecins ne s'attendent pas à faire face
à un grave problème de santé
mauvaise passe pour les gens qui passent
peu de temps sur le site il n'y a pas à
s'inquiéter du niveau d'amiante pour les
gens qui travaillent plus longtemps sur
le site comme les sauveteurs les
travailleurs c'est beaucoup plus
préoccupant
les autorités locales et fédérales
affirme que l'ère de manhattan ne
présente aucun danger et qu'il n'y a
aucun risque d'épidémie 6 mai le
ministère de la santé a fait dépêcher
ici une équipe de 35 médecins
spécialistes
par précaution